(gentle music)
- [Chris] This is a very special song
going out to a very special somebody.
We may not be together anymore,
but I miss you more than the world.
♪ There comes a point
in every man's life ♪
♪ When he thinks about settling down ♪
♪ Moving on from all
the one-night stands ♪
♪ And the girls just messing around ♪
♪ Wishing it was like the simpler times ♪
♪ When romance was for life ♪
♪ So I asked my grandmother
for relationship advice ♪
♪ Have you got any single friends ♪
♪ 'Cause I like them wrinkly ♪
♪ If they're looking for a younger man ♪
♪ Please tell them to ring me ♪
♪ Because I lust after
ladies who are more mature ♪
♪ Preferably they've lived
through both World Wars ♪
♪ Wrinkly ♪
♪ I like them wrinkly ♪
♪ I met a gal called Gladys,
she said, hello handsome ♪
♪ You're old enough to be my
great-great-great-grandson ♪
♪ She gave me her number,
I handed her mine ♪
♪ I had my first time having
phone sex on a landline ♪
♪ I love how her hair's
so naturally white ♪
♪ And the only way she'll ghost
me is if she actually dies ♪
♪ There's no need to worry
about meeting her parents ♪
♪ Or getting pregnant, 'cause
she's way past the menopause ♪
♪ I fell for her, she fell for me ♪
♪ But not literally,
'cause she's elderly ♪
♪ She's wrinkly ♪
♪ I like them wrinkly ♪
♪ You can call me old-fashioned ♪
♪ But I like 'em old-fashioned ♪
♪ Before I know what's happened,
got her bra unfastened ♪
♪ They're wrinkly ♪
♪ And I like them wrinkly ♪
♪ Gladys draws the curtains,
lights a candelabra ♪
♪ Puts on a vinyl of sex
jams, all Frank Sinatra ♪
♪ She takes out her dentures,
I take off my shirt ♪
♪ She takes off her blouse,
and then her Medical Alert ♪
♪ I try to hide my desire,
but it's hopeless ♪
♪ I wanna jump her bones
like osteoporosis ♪
♪ She's had a double hip replacement ♪
♪ So I ask what should I do ♪
♪ She pulls me close and whispers ♪
♪ Let's wear these ones out too ♪
♪ I'm a whippersnapper with senior fever ♪
♪ No need for silver foxes ♪
♪ Once I've seen your silver beaver ♪
♪ Now we're acting all flirty,
getting down and dirty ♪
♪ She's 99, so we her age minus 30 ♪
♪ When we make love I tell
her back it up further ♪
♪ And after we're done, I
get a packet of Werther's ♪
♪ She's kinky ♪
♪ And ever so wrinkly ♪
♪ I say to her, Gladys,
I'm so glad it's you ♪
♪ She says, put it in me,
I'll put you in my will ♪
♪ You and I were meant
to be, so enter me ♪
♪ My vagina's like a time
machine of the last century ♪
♪ So I'll sing this song for
you, a romantic serenade ♪
♪ Then I'll sing it louder ♪
♪ Because you lost your hearing aid ♪
♪ You're wrinkly ♪
♪ And I love you wrinkly ♪
Gladys, I love you, and
I miss you so, so much.